how's it going bros my name is fear ah
so today we're going to pax
you bros are coming along I'm going to
meet up with some friends that I haven't
met in so long or even ever so that's
weird
alright you boys ready let's go look
who's here you guys
ha yeah camera my face I'll stab you I'm
sorry I'm so sorry
also hey hey my hair is real yeah mmm
looking good it's good I like it
bring out for breakfast alone although I
already had Braille be fun we can't find
a place we can we just wait yes
everywhere is busy I think jelly has
eaten already so he's diverting us these
losers Oh at least Mary knows how to
work it there you go ken thank you
we're gonna pax yay
this is cool we're up on stage and I'm
not playing for these geyser and playing
some hockey look at Felix who wants
Felix to win
I just read a few fans on me gave me
this
get your hair so the council we are oh
yeah we got like a garage no one cared
like we would be right here
I'm sure God children the Vegas one
attention it's okay let's just give it
to them yeah we're going to check out
the Indian mega boy yeah okay cool
Jack get out of my shot I'm trying to
get it focused there we go yes
okay
oh there's always say when snow that
would blue that way yeah go away get out
of my mom okay you don't know hungry I'm
stupid we're going to get food in this
super fancy huge car hey break it out
lunch
that's how [ __ ] cool
your job can you did it is a gay bomb
people
right he really sucks he's got like
eight times in a row now you'll get it
[ __ ] you it hit
oh my god who is this it's crying oh my
god is cry no oh my god show your face
from what all right Yoshi the base shows
your freeze-dried what's your oh
all right it's 8:45 I got back like
three hours ago and I passed out I was
just too much for me I woke up at 5:00
this morning because I was um dead light
and then no there's a party going on
right now and all my friends are there
and I think I have to go you know I'm
really tired and I think I'm gonna throw
up
poor me um I don't think I'll block it
though I'll see you tomorrow
good night all right pres um today's a
new day I had a lot of fun yesterday I'm
really glad I actually went out I forced
myself I felt bad the first half-hour it
was worth day it's so dark Jesus Christ
now we're heading out we're doing the
panel it's gonna be a lot of fun I'll
see you there
indeedy hey we're doing the panel
I'm ready Thank You sock I know I'm
asking other very masculine look how
many people showed up you lock up people
too it's pretty exciting oh my god
people yelling he's excited
he's definitely excited
thing
yes
why I bought
I think
my turn you guys want to be on YouTube
yeah
these are all smashed Oh alright we're
doing a signing thing come on mark
playing jackass student stuff we're
making these people wait I feel bad -
reaiiy - shirt yes
daddy's in Asia
we just finished signing a lot of fun
and now we're gonna go to like a power
okay don't touch me okay it's super
windy outside
you're about to see it can you feel a
Miss apparently
kind of a big deal I'm there too
shut up why are you so angry I'm almost
like the heat
all right we're leaving packs I'm not
coming back
what are you - hey I'm back back with
the pugs yeah and I am editing the vlog
that you'll Edgar comes along that
you're watching right now and I just
wanted to say I just wanted to say thank
you to everyone that I met at pax it was
such a great time because of all of you
guys friends or fans or whatever if you
enjoyed this vlog thumb it up I'm
definitely gonna do more if you bros
enjoy them I have a lot more traveling
coming up September and October it's
going to be insane I've been prepping
for this for so long but anyway thank
you for watching in Brophy students